hello I'm on
sorry I was getting my clock ready
so don't go over hello everybody Welcome
uh this is what's new in C sharp 11. uh
the title of this talk that I submitted
and the abstract that I submitted uh was
mainly jokes about
the parameter null checking feature of C
sharp 11 because there was all this
drama about it and lots of people saw it
as the downfall of the language
um and I was gonna
talk about that
um probably make fun of it a bit but uh
as you may have heard that's been canned
uh as yeah well see I actually like this
feature but I'm not going to get into it
um it is interesting though to still
just talk very briefly about
well my position is it wasn't the sign
of the downfall of the language now it
definitely isn't since it's not in but
actually the fact that it's been removed
is almost like proof because the team
actually did listen to all of the
feedback and said yeah right fair enough
but there is still some or one in
particular feature that you might think
is maybe a sign of the Apocalypse
um but it is a good reminder to
everybody that if you have strong
opinions one way the other about any of
the features that I'm showing or that
I've planned uh C sharp is open source
you can provide feedback if you don't
want to do it on GitHub Twitter Works
arguably better than GitHub but so what
we're actually going to do today is I'm
just going to run through a bunch of the
C sharp 11 features I'm going to focus
on the ones that you can use right now
if you get Visual Studio 2022 preview
that's all I'm using for demos
everything's going to work but there's
like heaps of features so
I'm happy for this to be like as
interactive as you like if you have
questions yell out if I'm waffling on if
you want to get on to the next feature
yell that out too uh we can somehow form
a democracy I don't know uh we'll work
it out so the first uh feature we're
going to talk about is raw string
literals
um and so
I have one slide per feature and then
I'm just going to visual studio it up
basically rostering literals so the
first two uh strings on the screen there
is the I guess old way of doing things
um that you're all used to and
essentially you can see that we have to
escape quotes strings are delimited by
quotes therefore if you want to quote in
your string you have to tell the
compiler this is not the end of a string
great
so the rostering literal is on the
bottom and a rostering literal has one
sort of headline feature you will never
have to escape any character
that's the that's the broad thing so
let's
talk about it a bit
um
actually let's go over to here
oops do here okay so raw string literals
uh this uh this little tool here uh you
put in some code and then you put in two
different alternate versions of the code
and it shows you a diff of what they
look like once they're decompiled
uh so if I scroll down here and we can
see this is just to prove that it works
the only difference here is the
exclamation mark So raw string literals
having this string over two lines is
exactly the same as having this string
over two lines it's exactly the strain
is having this string with a new line in
the middle there's nothing special about
how they output the whole idea is you
just don't have to escape anything so if
I come over to visual studio so a
rostering literally is three talking
marks which is a lot I agree
um
actually you know what it doesn't
actually it can just be on one line
that's totally fine if I want to go you
know hello
like that
um that looks a bit weird because it's
four now there we go um and so the idea
is I can just put in my quotes as you
can see there
um I can put in new lines if I make it a
multi-line raw string literal which
means the first line has to start on the
next line which is a bit weird but
hopefully it'll all make sense in a
second
um I can put in tab characters I can put
in all the normal stuff that you would
have to escape I don't have to escape
this is the you know the feature
um the thing that's interesting about
them is you'll notice that everything on
this line if I just go you know make
some more lines everything on these
subsequent lines here is indented by
four spaces
one of the other features of rostering
literals is it allows you to make your
code look a bit nicer right if this was
a of a Verbatim string
I would have to go
um like this I can go hello
I have to expect my talking marks and I
have to start putting the rest of this
string
at character Zero
right
and so I mean that's not a big deal but
if you've got code that's indented
already because of braces and whatever
it kind of looks a bit funny
um I find this all the time in unit
tests where I'm testing a bunch of data
and I'm over here in my test and as soon
as I want a multi-line string I'm now
back over here it's weird so raw spring
literals sort of fix that and actually
if you look zoom in see that vertical
line there in Visual Studio what that is
doing
that's showing you where the sort of
logical start of each line is not the
actual start and if I just move this
sorry magnifier if I move this end
quotes backwards and forwards you can
see that line move right so that's the
end quotes Define where this this string
logically starts everything before that
is is ignored and so again that's that's
really cool as well for like unit
testing the other cool thing about this
for unit testing is let's say for
example you were testing a web service
and you might want to have some Json so
the really cool thing about this
I love is
I can put in my test data
which is absolutely not valid
um and the best thing about this is I
can copy this test data and I can paste
it into Postman and I can see if my
thing works or I can get a result from
Postman and paste it into my code as an
expected output and I don't do any more
work which is like saves you hours per
day so that's really cool and you can
see I don't have to escape my Escape my
quotes which is great
the question then becomes well how do I
make this like often what I want to do
here I don't want to hard code this name
I want this to be
uh some interpolation so how do I do
that and so the way I do that is I use a
dollar sign to get an interpolated raw
string right makes sense
but
remember I said you don't have to escape
anything right see my code has errors
here because these braces are now
confusing in normal interpolated strings
we escape them with double
braces
with raw strings you don't have to
escape anything so this is where we get
a little bit crazy if we put two dollar
signs
we're now telling the compiler that in
interpolation use is two braces
so now I have a valid thing other than I
haven't find name but I'm I trust you
can understand that I haven't escaped
any characters from my data you can kind
of say maybe I've escaped my my
interpolation holes but you know that's
you can argue everyone
so the reason this gets a bit crazy is
how do we deal with quotes say I want
three quotes in my string right I want
this
to be this even though it's not
validation oh no I have a mistake how do
we fix this well you make four
which actually hang on oh hang on see
this is the editor has uh has helped me
here bye there we go so now my inter my
raw string has four double quotes which
means I can use one two or three double
quotes in my string without it and yes
you can just keep going and eventually
the editor gives up trying to help you
but
um whoops oh hang on
yay this is valency sharp
um and in fact so is this and I can just
keep going and I can just do this for an
hour and that's part of the talk so
you know hopefully you won't do this I'm
kind of surprised there isn't more
feedback online about oh no this is the
downfall of language because it can get
silly but you know I suspect that most
people there'll be one dollar sign maybe
two there'll be three quotes you know
we'll all live happily ever after
um
and that's basically roasting literals
there's not much to them and in fact as
far as
uh like you can see here as far as the
decompilation goes like it's just a
string there's nothing really special
the one thing you can't do with them is
so there's no such thing as a Verbatim
raw string because they are
already raw right they're already
verbatim so the at sign is not valid but
apart from that they're just strings
um so yeah they're kind of cool the the
only in fact the biggest downside to
royal spring literals and why maybe you
don't want to adopt them everywhere is
that uh like github's code highlighting
doesn't know about them yet so
um cool
list patterns okay who likes patterns
does anyone like patterns I love
patterns
who's neutral doesn't want to raise
their hand cool so list patterns are
cool list patterns sorry I should talk
about this uh list patterns are like all
other patterns
um mainly a way to simplify code checks
so if we Imagine X in this case is an
intera I guess
I can check you know is there at least
three items in the list does it start
with one does it end with ten I can do
that in that first line of code or I can
do that in that second line of code and
if you've never seen a pattern before or
if you've never seen a list pattern
before yes it looks weird don't worry I
will explain so the way this works
is let me get rid of all this
let me
pretend we get it into a
so the way this works is essentially
what we're doing is we're saying
if my array
looks like this
so if my array X has three elements
first one's one say one's two that one's
three
that syntax is hopefully not too crazy
right we can understand it that's
awkward
and that's essentially a list pattern
right that's
not the simplest list pattern because I
guess the simplest would be if there's
one element but that's what that's what
this is doing
where things get maybe a bit more
confusing though is each one of these
things in my list pattern is itself or
can be another pattern so I can say this
should be not null
now it doesn't make sense for rinse but
we'll ignore that right so now this is
saying hey here's an array of I guess I
can make this
we can shut the compiler up
um is my array three elements long first
one's two second one first one's one
second one's two third one I don't care
what it is as long as it's not null
that might be useful
um if I make this let's make this a
string array
so I can do something like a
that's it but what if I want
any why didn't that work oh because
there's a string around Char right right
sorry
um so that's cool
what if I don't know how long I want my
rate to be well that's where I can use
dot dot which is the range syntax if you
haven't seen it before from C sharp ten
nine something and what this says is
there at least two elements in my array
the first one being a the last one being
Z could be any number in the middle they
could be anything
um and in fact what I can do I can say
is there any number of elements in the
middle of the A and the Z also give me
them into this variable called subarray
and you can see that's a Char array
so I can pull out bits of my array and
work with them as well as checking
boundaries one thing that I quite like
with this because it kind of gets a bit
funny to
talk about this in the abstract sense
let me just write a little
sample here I've actually used this in
anger and I think it's quite effective
so if I split this path
into elements right
list patterns is a really cool way to
sort of analyze the path and maybe uh
pull stuff out of it so for example
I don't care where my software is
installed so I'm going to start with the
dot dot but it has to be installed in a
you know a directory called when
yourself and then from there I want to
pull out the components and
I don't know
let's do that right
what this is saying is hey is the path
given to me is it a path I recognize but
I don't care how it starts with which is
kind of nice
and then
am I in the component subfolder and then
have I been given the path to a
component and if so what is the name of
that component
and this VAR actually is probably
probably what you want to do is do
something like this to say it shouldn't
be null just in case although I know you
know string split's not going to put in
any nulls but my way so you can sort of
do some like parsing as well as your
checks which is interesting and then now
I can just you know party on name it's
just a string I can do what I want
um so it gets kind of cool if we go into
sharp lab
um can have a look at how this works uh
let's go with a string
so with a string which you can sort of
treat as a Char array
so I can do my a dot dot Z
as we can see on the right what the
compiler is actually doing so the first
thing is doing is a length check right
we've specified two elements so we know
it has to be at least two notice it's
greater than or equal to two not three
so the dot dot could be empty
right and then we're checking if it
starts with Asus if we wanted to make it
so that hey it has to have at least one
thing between the A and Z a and the Z we
can do that
by adding another pattern in this case
the discard pattern because I don't want
to actually capture that value I just
want to make sure there's at least one
thing so now our length check is for
three
and then you know I can do all sorts of
things if I make this a
a list of strings
then
make these into Strings
oops
no thank you
there we go
um so I can
I can do things like well this is a
string so I want to make sure the length
is greater than zero
so this is a property pattern inside a
list pattern and you can see down here
so now whoops the compiler check the
account properties have length property
so it knows what's going on
it's pulling out the bits of the string
it's checking them for length like it
you know this is saving you that code
essentially so it can be a bit confusing
at first but once you get used to
patterns
um they can be really powerful they can
also be really confusing and it's
definitely a use sparingly type thing
um
so the scope of the VAR is interesting
um if I do
so we should be able to see it here
uh no I probably need to use it hang on
compilers being too smart
so
one of the reasons this has go-to's in
it which obviously you would never write
because you'd be you know it'll be used
on Twitter
um one of the reasons for this is to
capture that variable so we can see here
this this text too is essentially my X
that I defined there and it's defined at
the very top so I can
uh I think I can use it out here as well
or my inside if no okay so it's on the
inside the f
okay that's interesting so for out
statements that's
not how that works which is interesting
um but yeah so in inside here is
normally where you'd use it which
actually that does make sense because
then you can do it without conflicting
names
um but yeah all of that stuff you know
like
uh for example like if I change this to
objects I can make this
string uh yeah length doesn't work now
all of the different types of patterns
all work within there so type patterns
and property patterns and whatever
um
yeah
cool definitely spends any
cool okay uh UT effects ringless rules
I'm
probably not going to bother demoing
this unless someone wants me to because
this is relatively niche but you can do
it now because it it's in the yes
um what this is this used to be a little
bit more
um like common a scenario but then there
was a compiler change a language change
a couple of weeks ago so what this is is
a way of specifying binary data but it
looks nicer
it's called utf-8 string literals but my
recommendation is not to think of it as
a string literal because it's not and
actually I will I will demo that because
it's kind of interesting so the way you
do this is you just use the u8 suffix on
a string
and that s variable there is binary data
that represents the utf-8 encoding of
that string which is you know 65 66 67
if anyone knows asking the interesting
thing about this is that if I Mouse over
VAR and if you can read the relatively
small text it's not a string
um don't think of this as a string you
can't use string operations on it it's a
read-only span
the reason it's a read-only span is
performance it used to be in the first
versions of this feature that would have
been a byte array and that's
maybe a bit more common that you might
have a byte array in your code and then
it might be nicer to replace it with a
utf-8 string
this is a this is sort of a language
request that comes from asp.net because
all of their headers like you know HTTP
headers when they're passing them Etc
they check you know does this start with
HTTP one or two or whatever it is all of
that is utf-8 data and for performance
they don't treat it as strings they
treat it as byte arrays as binary data
so they do lots of comparisons for is
this a known essentially is this a known
string but it's actually is this a known
byte array and so then the code doesn't
look very nice because it's got lots of
magic numbers that you know with a
comment that says trust me this is the
word you know whatever
so this is just a way of encoding binary
data it is not a string
um you can get back to a byte array by
calling two array on the read-only span
the way this works is actually really
interesting
uh if we jump into sharp lab
well it's interesting if you like that
sort of thing
um so the way your string actually gets
encoded directly into the dll
this private static read on the int blah
blah blah blah that is then not
supported it is a read-only span over
the memory from your actual dll so when
when we say this is for Perth like this
is there is no allocations here at all
this is reading an array of memory that
is directly coming from your assembly
which is kind of cool just not in
everybody's domain of what their program
has to do well I don't know what
happened there
okay
um so yeah that's UTF right roasting
little uh I'm sorry there is also utf-8c
utf-8 raw string literals
um
there's not much with them if you if you
need them they're good if you don't
you'll probably never see them
all right required members this is
probably the one that I would imagine
most of you will use and maybe will be
good uh so I'll probably talk about this
a bit more than the rest I think 20
minutes in those that's right
required numbers Okay so
required members is you can now Mark a
member as required essentially
so in the old days if we wanted to
define a class called person with a
first name and we had to require people
to provide a first name we'd have to use
a Constructor
it's not a huge price to pay but you
have to
um if we let me just create that class
so Constructors you know they're not
they're not a bad thing but over the
years C sharp has sort of been moving
away well not away from Constructors but
providing other ways to do these things
so for example we have in it only
properties now so I can say this
this first name
it can only be set when you're creating
this object it can't be set afterwards
right it's immutable we also have
nullable so I can say that this middle
name is essentially optional
you can leave it unset
and string last name
and if you've ever done this
you're probably familiar with These
Warnings I've got here which is nullable
analysis saying hey you said first name
couldn't be null but you haven't
provided a value for it
you've got to fix that right because
otherwise someone can go new person oh
yeah
appear
and if I go P DOT first name dot two
string I'm going to get a null reference
exception
if I did that on middle name
well I still get no reference exception
but the compiler is at least warning me
hey this could be null with first name
I've said it's not null
but I haven't done anything about
actually making that no so in the old
days what we used to do is we'd probably
do that maybe to say yeah yeah just shut
up compiler that's what I do
and that's cool like if you've got this
data coming from you know Json
serialization and you know that that
first name is definitely always going to
be there then you know go for it it's
your code
compiler is only suggesting
um but it's a bit annoying so what the
required property does
the way I like to think about it is it
shifts the blame you'll notice the
squiggle has gone from first name in my
class but it's now on person in my
construction of the person because
rather than the class author having to
supply a first name the required keyword
is said whoever creates this person they
have to provide a first name and so if I
do that
in whoops
if I do that here
Maya's go away
I'm now creating a well most of them I'm
now creating a person I'm providing the
first name so the compiler is happy with
my Constructor use the property has
required which means the compiler knows
that whoever creates this will have to
supply first name we're all good uh last
name I can do the same thing
it's now back to errors we have an error
specific to last name because it knows
I'm not setting last name
so
this to me kind of rounds out that
nullable
I mean not the nullable feature but you
know that that way that you define
classes with I want to use null ability
I want to use object initializers or
records or whatever you know the newer
style of C sharp maybe
um but I don't have to fight the
compiler
and still use a Constructor of course
so if I create a Constructor that takes
in these two names for example
first name equals first
at last
so I can still create a Constructor and
that looks cool
but something interesting uh well sorry
that's just saying there's no
Constructor so I need a I need another
Constructor there we go
so this is all cool and there's no
errors but something interesting happens
here if we try to use this Constructor
so if I create another person
whoops
we get an error
and this is a bit weird this is the the
gotcha with required properties and what
this says is you haven't provided a
value for first name and last name
and that's a bit weird the reason is
essentially as with nullable analysis
and most things in general the compiler
doesn't do deep introspection of your
code so if you like you know draw a
horizontal line in your mind here at
line 11.
the compiler is not going to look into
that Constructor I'm calling and see
what it does because that could be
disastrous right that could call another
method it could use reflection it could
do whatever it does it could hit a
database the compiler can't do that so
this is basically the honor System the
way this works or the way we can make
this work is I can add an attribute to
this to this Constructor called sets
required members which just tells the
compiler if anyone calls this
Constructor don't error
it doesn't do any checks right if I
remove this
still no errors everyone's happy except
for oh actually maybe not
oh there you go oh right so now I'm back
to my nullable warning yeah okay well so
if we didn't have a nullable right the
required members part of the compiler
would not complain about that which is a
bit weird
um
there was a question I saw on
somewhere a Discord last night uh about
this which is why do we need this if we
have nullable right I'm said here that
middle name is not is not required I've
said that first name is required by
virtue of making them uh not null if I
create the Constructor you know why do
we need this
essentially the answer or my answer I
don't know about any official answers is
a you might not like to use Constructors
they sometimes get annoying you know you
can have lots and lots of properties
sometimes that's a pain
um but B
you have to think about this feature
completely separately from null ability
so to me it closes a gap with
nullability but there is absolutely
nothing wrong with me saying that this
middle name is required
just because it's not nullable doesn't
mean I can't make it required and I can
totally just go here and I can say yeah
it's not that's fine if null is a valid
value that's one thing and if someone
has to specify a value for middle name
that's a completely separate thing that
value I specify could be null
so again maybe for your code
that's not relevant and if you trust
where your data is coming from you don't
need to worry but
the whole story
any questions yes yes spins so you don't
need no ability enabled for the required
so the completely completely separate
features so if I
um remove this
so so if I remove this and make middle
name non-null right this is now giving
me null ability squigglies if I disable
nullability they go away but all my
required checks would still be in place
so this is still complaining about first
name
so they're completely separate separate
features and this is generally there's a
few features of c-sharp where this sort
of comes out where if you look at these
three features together
it's one of them is not required but
essentially you can't look at them
together right the compiler team has to
make each Feature A A constrained thing
um
is there any more questions yes
throwing some Jason and
good question
yeah oops I just copied and celebrated
yes so this is so much like null ability
this is just a compile time feature
um
I
oh okay I have to fake sharp lab is
on.net6 and this requires dotnet7 so I
just have to fake some.net seven types
won't be a second
um
yeah to answer your question
um yeah so this is just compile time so
Json deserialization reflection any of
those things they'll happily work but
then that's true of nullable as well
right you can have a nullable property
set it null via reflection no worries
um
what am I doing creating an attribute so
it is it is compile time only
which is something to sort of be aware
of you do need to know where your data
is coming from
um the only thing that
well
the the thing the only other thing
that's interesting there is the if
you've got a generic method and use the
new constraint
um that one because like that's not
runtime that's compile time
so the compiler enforces that in in the
sense that if you have any required
properties then your class can't conform
to that new constraint
so depending on how you're doing
reflection or whatever it could be okay
right if you've got a generic method
that uses activated or create instance
you probably can't call that generic
method anymore but you can call
activator.create instance if you try
hard enough
let me just create this one more
attribute and I can show you how this
works
and this one needs a Constructor
oh thank you
we have.net 7 everybody
um
you thought making a framework was hard
so what can we see here so there's a
couple of things
you know since we're talking about
reflection anyway any class that has any
required members will have this required
member attribute uh any required member
obviously we'll have this required
member attribute
um the
Constructor gets this compiler features
required and an obsolete attribute this
is a bit weird and in the weeds of
compilers which maybe you don't care
about but here we go this is essentially
so old compilers will not create
not let you create an instance of this
class so the obsolete attribute causes
an old compiler to error because it's
got a property on the end here that says
error true so if you use this from a old
project you try to call a library that
has required members your compiler will
error and say hey I don't know what this
means something could go wrong
the compiler features required is then
the formalization of doing that instead
of using the obsolete method the
compiler is going to move to this new
attribute
but the compiler is only going to move
to that so all of the old compilers
don't support it yet so now we we're in
this transition phase where we do both
um but essentially that's that's all
there is to it really you get this
little attribute and that's all there is
so if you're referencing a nougat
package and they have required members
the compiler will look at these
attributes and all the same things will
work this is It's compiler only not
runtime but that doesn't mean it's
limited just to source code if that
makes sense
foreign
static abstract interface members this
one's
interesting
um because this one is a c-sharp
language feature that is
somewhat
I don't know whether it's relevant but
it's come somewhat small but there's a
whole runtime element to this as well so
what this is is basically what it says
on the tin which is interfaces can now
have static abstract methods
um
previously you know interfaces well the
abstract is kind of redundant but
unfortunately because of previous
c-sharp language versions you have to
have it because you could always have
static members on interfaces
um
but essentially I have an interface here
called I animal
it says anyone who implements eye animal
eye animal has to have a property called
can walk that's not exciting but
in this case the property is static
cool the way this were or the where you
want to use this the way this makes
sense is in generic types so my method
at the bottom there is a generic type
takes in a t we don't know what T is but
we say that t has to be at the very
least it has to be an i animal and so
once we know that we can now call this
can walk property on T whatever T is
Right might be a dog might be a cat
whatever we can call it on T so normally
you would need to do dog dot can walk
cat dot can work obviously in order to
type out the word dog you need to know
what type it is if you have a generic
method you don't know what type it is
so that's the feature and that may or
may not be useful to you um there's lots
of advantages to this uh it's pretty
common in interfaces to have
properties that sort of represent data
about the type like this can walk for
example but because it's not an
interface you end up having to Define it
as an instance property so then your
generic method has to create an instance
of it or get given one so that it can
call these things so if you can do that
statically then you know that's a little
bit of a perf gain you might not create
so many objects and things
but where this is going to have the
biggest impact on everybody is that the
runtime.net7 has adopted this and this
is the foundation of the new generic
math feature that you might have heard
about which I'm not going to talk about
even though it's not a c-sharp feature I
don't care and basically what what are
we going to do let's add let's write an
ad method
so
we're going to add two numbers together
we've got to return a plus b great
I don't even know what that is oh it's
not called yeah well I'm fixing that
um there we go we're adding two numbers
together great wonderful
um this is cool we can all write this
code but
it's not very flexible because I can't
add 2 to 3.2 and so I can go in here and
I can make these all decimals
and now this code compiles oh actually
probably doesn't because I probably need
to tell it it's a decimal so that's
annoying I guess if I made them floats
then that would be okay maybe
still need to put an F okay open F
anyway
um this would then presumably the answer
would be 5.20001
um but so this is you know it's a bit
annoying right I'm sort of limited what
I really want to do is run add method I
don't actually care about data types
um you might have your own custom
integer type maybe maybe you're fancy
so what we can do is we can make this
generic this is why generics were
invented
oh
keyboard use is hard
so I can make this generic this all
works except this call doesn't work
anymore because
how do we add two random types together
don't know
fortunately it turns out that plus in C
sharp is not really a plus it's actually
a method call and it's a method call
called op underscore Edition and it
turns out it's static
the main reason this whole language
feature exists is because
um
well a man named Tanner wanted wanted to
be able to call static methods so if I
say hey T has to be a number
my addition operator now works
now I have a generic ad method it's that
easy folks
um this is all because this eye number
defines a an operator which happens to
be a static method
that adds two numbers together
the interesting thing is when we go to
the look at I number
um so our number defines a bunch of
stuff which is cool
but most importantly it implements a
bunch of interfaces it actually
implements like a whole lot of
interfaces like a really a lot and this
is cool there's a little Quirk here with
all of these ones the runtime defines
which is all of the t's have to be an
implementation of itself with itself as
the like generic it gets a bit funny but
the compiler works it out so who cares
that's the only thing your symptoms is
like what the anyway
um but this is cool and if you have some
time you know in your free time looking
through this is is interesting there's
some interesting little things here so
in particular if we go to
addition I believe yeah so I number
implements I Edition operators and guess
what here's our static abstract method
right this is the plus operator that I'm
calling from my generic method the
reason this works is
I'm essentially you know it doesn't look
like this in C sharp but I'm kind of
doing this
um yeah
well as I say it doesn't work in C sharp
but that's what I'm doing right this is
just a static method call this little
thing here
um
so there's a bunch of these interfaces
now in the runtime that enable all this
support and that's cool we can do things
like
um hands up in the room if you've ever
re-implemented math
hello Aaron
um so we can do things like you know
uh T dot identity no infinite zero
this is what zero is right and I mean I
can even you know I can create a class
here and I can say yeah I Implement I
number
and and I can go uh public static goo
zero equals I don't know there you go
there's zero like you can you can
Implement these things as well if you
want there's a there's a lot to
implement obviously in this
um
but so
it does get interesting this does
actually get useful to like obviously
math itself is useful
um as much as I hate it
but there's more here that's actually so
one one I quite like is I parsable
I parsable of t means I can now call on
either of these A or B methods I can
call parse or try sorry sorry not on T I
can call pars or tripath now this to me
is really useful right this is saying I
don't care what type you've given me
I'm going to call tripars and convert
from a string to whatever you are I
could see like lots of ways that could
be useful in fact I probably would have
in the past created my own sort of form
of this where I had an instance method
that did this work and it was just this
wasted you know why do I need an object
to do this so there's a bunch of there's
a bunch of goodness in.net now
um if I can get back to I number
probably to type it in
um so yeah there's a bunch of goodness
in.net that now uses this
um so formattable you can form oh no
sorry formattables there's uh span
formatable span pausable or cool so if
you've got
um spans you want to save some memory
you can now use them generically
addition multiplication comparison all
these things
um all of this stuff is
enabled by Static abstract members but
obviously is part of dotnet7
but you can then use you know any part
of this to maybe light up some new
things in your code
the other thing this is really useful
for and I don't know if there's a an
existing
um if there's an existing interface for
this but one thing I quite like is I can
go interface I async factory
and I can go um
static abstract
uh what was it sorry it's going to be a
t and I got to do where T is an eye
async Factory of T I think
I'm Gonna Leave it off and maybe the
compiler will tell me so create a sink I
guess this is a task
um that's a really useful interface
because we don't have async Constructors
in C sharp but now we can call await
create on any old type that you just tag
with this iacing Factory and away we go
that's really cool and possibly might
even mean that we'll never get async
Constructors because we kind of don't
need them
um as I say I don't think there's
anything inbuilt in this in.net but I
could totally see if dotnet eight or
nine or whatever gets some I async
whatever Factory that becomes popular
that you know that might be how we do
all these things
so this one's the feature that I could
see everyone using the most
but it's going to be probably highly
specific how you use it right based on
your domain and what you do
um there's a bunch of potentially memory
savings you could get if you've got this
pattern where you use instance members
for what really should be static because
you couldn't do static and then there's
a bunch of other stuff like factories
and whatever you can get from that
any other questions I think that's my
last like
yeah so that was the last feature that
works right now and if you want to play
with any of that go get vs2022 preview
go nuts uh the only thing you need to do
is
we bring out the project file so Target
framework seven for required properties
for static Etc static abstract or not
for static abstracts but for math
although possibly static objects as well
and then Lang version preview
and then
uh I think there's another
no maybe it's just language I think
there's another I think you have to opt
into another preview thing for static
math but that might have been removed
that sorry no that was only for.net6 a
lot of this stuff actually came out and
previewed on that six and to get
feedback so that it can come out
properly done seven so yeah Don is 75.
um but yeah so you can go play with any
of that
these things are all new features of C
sharp 11 that I can't demo easily
um but I'm happy to talk about them or
any one of them or any of the other
stuff I've talked about so we're about
40 minutes does anyone have any
questions or I'm just gonna
I mean I can do this all day literally I
just nope okay cool
um and some of these are really like
tiny
um new lines in interpolation dolls
actually I think that one is in vs now
um this this one is really like
so I can go hello name
uh I guess I better need a name
uh I can now do this
there you go that's a new line in
interpolation hold so some of these are
tiny um this is just like one of those
things I think this was the guy who was
implementing rostering literals was like
surprised you couldn't do this and it
was like does anyone mind if I comment
out this little you know thing
um
so that's called top level statement
attributes uh actually I don't think I
don't know if that's going ahead the
idea here is uh let me bring up sharp
lab so if I top level statements which
you may or may not be familiar with is
the whole you know I don't need a class
I don't need a thing I do need a using
statement
um
they synthesize a main method so there
is still a main method there is still a
program class you just didn't have to
write it and so
you couldn't ever write attributes on
that main method what this feature is
that you can go basically uh main you
know whatever and it will output an
attribute as I say this isn't
implemented yet I think this one
actually might not make it because I
think it got into some really tricky
compiler specific things
um that's pretty much just for like
winforms web form WPF type stuff where
you need to say I want to be a single
threaded apartment you can't use new
stuff
um delegation for static methods that
one's a good one
so now I need to remember how to demo
this we go void M and we take an action
yep
and then we have another method here
and then
we call M and we pass a Lambda that
calls n
and whoops or we just do that
I think that's right
yeah
yeah nope it's not right okay well
actually so this is actually this is the
old code I need to make these methods
static uh and uh maybe that means I
can't use top level anyway see these two
lines here right this is my call of M
with the Lambda at the top and not with
the lamp to the bottom
this looks like a complete mess because
these type names are fake and you can't
type them but what this is doing is
saying hey use this field
which is this field
or if it's null initialize the field and
then use it and so this is a form of
caching that happens with lambdas and it
happens everywhere and it's for
performance it doesn't happen if you
just use the method name directly
and so that means it's got worse
performance but it looks a lot nicer and
so a lot of people do it and a lot of
people come and go I can improve your
performance well it needed a spec change
to allow this but essentially the
compiler now makes these two lines the
same so if you want the neat format of
passing methods as though they're
lambdas you now can
um it is actually quite nice uh generic
attributes
relatively straightforward so if you've
got an attribute where you have to pass
in type of blah you don't need to do
type of anymore you can make it generic
that's all as far as I know there aren't
any attributes in.net that use this yet
but one day they will be
um name of parameter
so you couldn't previously do
this
name of a
you couldn't previously do this uh
because it would say I don't know what a
is because it's outside the method and a
is inside the method you now can
I told you these aren't very exciting
um pattern matching on read-only span
this is one of those ones where again if
you have read on these bands of chars
you will love this because you don't
have to convert the strings anymore
um in fact I'm not even going to demo if
you don't have read on the spans of char
don't worry about it
um relax ordering of ref and partial I
couldn't tell you what the order of
reference partial was but I now know
that it's relaxed
um I think he used to do partial ref but
for some reason people like saying ref
partial I don't know why
semi-auto properties is is an
interesting one actually that one's
worth
um that one's worth thinking too and
I would have done this as part of
required properties but it doesn't work
yet right
um there's rumors that this might not
make it in as well because I think even
yeah there's a branch here but I don't
know how up today it is what semi-auto
properties are
so I've got my class person right and I
can make my required string name
which actually probably won't work
because this Branch doesn't have the
required stuff in it
or sharp Labs just died
we're just going to go back to me
so uh okay it's required okay we have
our property we're going to pretend is
required great so we've said it's not
null we've said you have to set it but
we can't say anything else about it
right we can't validate the property
what we want to do is we want to
validate it and I can do that by
putting in a a body for this get what
the why did that price go over there I
can put anybody over here and I can say
if value uh you know dot length is less
than three and I can throw an exception
or something
and I can go
well now what do I do
now I need somewhere to store this name
so now I need a field
and so now I need to provide a get as
well so adding this little bit of
validation has caused me to have to
write and expand all my properties out
which is kind of annoying so what
semi-auto properties means is
well I mean does is I now have this
magic keyword called field
and so what this says is the compiler is
going to do everything it does for
normal Auto properties
um
in fact I'm just gonna
hopefully you can remember what that
looked like
no what uh
so many brackets
okay so the compiler for a normal Auto
property generates a backing field right
a getter and a setup great so all this
does is semi semi-auto properties means
you can provide one of the two accesses
well actually you can provide both as
well still saves you defining a field
and instead of the field name just use
the field keyword and that if you like
is replaced with name k backing Fields
blah blah blah so you can do validation
you know you could put it in the getter
and do two upper or something on it so
it doesn't matter how it's set but
everyone will read it as to Upper it
saves you a bit of code but it actually
I think is really good I think that
two-upper example is a good reason for
why this is right if you to normally say
I want to expose this property as
uppercase but I won't allow anyone to
set it well you'd have to define a field
so then you go well I've if if I do the
two upper on the set
great every time I read it it'll be
uppercase and if someone reads the field
fine but what if someone sets the fields
or if you do the two upper on the get
that's fine except Nothing Stops someone
reading the field so I kind of like that
this just for constraining things to say
you have to use this property but you
can still provide logic
um
dim for static members like it's just so
weird so does anyone use default
Implement default interface members
yeah I didn't think so
um it's pretty Niche and so then now we
have static abstract interface members
and so now we also therefore have
default implementation members for
static abstract members which is that
you can provide static abstract member
but you can provide a default
implementation if the other class
doesn't I have no idea why you want to
do this but you might it's kind of super
Niche but there you go
param span of T that's a good one for
performance if you're into performance
so previously you could do you know
params int whatever
um but that's all you can now do
span events so
again it doesn't work don't know why I'm
sharp lad
um
this is you know a parameter well it's
not an array a parameter list
but directly on the memory
of whatever it comes from which means a
is less memory but also it means it's a
little bit more flexible right doesn't
have to be an array it could be a
something else
um so that's good for Perth uh
I don't know I've got refills there but
I do
but maybe the reference aren't you
anyway uh file types file types are
funny
so I'm just gonna go fish this year
looks better file types if we have a
class uh person
I can make this
internal which means only for this
assembly or I can make it public which
means for every other assembly
but what if I want to help a class to
deal with people or persons but I don't
want it to be seen by anyone else so I
can do file class you know person helper
that class is only visible in this file
literally this file which is kind of
cool it I mean you could do this before
with nested glasses was pretty common
but even nested classes like they then
appear in intellisense sometimes we
don't want them or you can have name
conflicts the name complex one is
especially annoying right if you have
this if you have a class helper in here
then its visibility is good but you
can't have any Properties or methods or
anything called helper anymore in this
class because you've now got a conflict
so file scope classes whoops
is is an interesting one
um
there's also
some math stuff and as previously stated
I don't like math so I'm not going to
talk about these but just to complete
the list
um unsigned right shift
yay
um
checked operators is is actually like
we might need to know about this we
maybe can't escape this
um I don't know whether anyone has
anyone used checked and unchecked like
mode in the compiler no it's again it's
pretty Niche but essentially you know
one mode you will get exceptions if you
do the wrong thing and the other mode
numbers will just loop around back to
zero uh you know more like C behavior
um so and you this was always it's
always been into sharp but you couldn't
Define different operator behaviors
under these conditions which was a bit
weird so now you can
um all of the math stuff uses checked
operators but I don't know if it'll leak
out
um the relaxed shift operator I love
they use the word relaxed
um what this means is that shift
operators so left shift and right shift
previously they could only be used on
ins and now they can be used on any type
you like you can just Define it shift
operator which does mean you can now
write C out less than less than string
like we all used to do in C if you write
the type the right you know operator in
class I'm sure someone will
um it's probably Aaron uh numeric in
pointer is this one's arguably
interesting again if you're like compile
a nerd or a math nerd or a.net nerd so
in pointer
so okay there's new types in C sharp 10
for Native int and Native unsigned int
which is fun because the the only reason
they're cool is because you get to say
nint and then you say nuint which you
always end up writing as
wrong you get there anyway
um these these types are mapped to in
pointer and unsigned in pointer
in previous versions versions of C sharp
but
in dot Net 7 and C sharp 11 they're now
their own sort of like they're a direct
representation of those types they're
not mapped to them which just sounds
weird and fruity and don't worry it
doesn't have any effect but what it does
mean is this feature essentially unlocks
the ability for the runtime team to
create new data types
that have no compromises without needing
c-sharp keywords so for example
you know int is in 32 long is in 64. the
runtime team can now create an INT 128
and everyone can use it and there won't
be a neat keyword for it like long long
or whatever they would have called it
but everything will just work so and a
lot of this is building up on this
static interface you know idea obviously
because now we can do math on it that's
the thing so this numeric uh pointer
stuff is the like piece of that puzzle
um it's over exciting there is actually
one more thing that I just realized I
don't have on the list here
and I maybe can show you does anyone use
structs
it's like two people yeah I don't ever I
try to avoid them
um I don't know how they work so is this
gonna work yeah uh previously this code
is invalid you couldn't Define a
parameter a parameter struct parameter a
Constructor
um the compiler synthesized one for you
because that's how Fields work
instruct so if I go uh you know hint x
equals one
you can see that x equals one goes into
the Constructor right the compiler had
to synthesize this now you can actually
Define your own the only if you don't
use drugs again you don't care if you do
use drugs that's cool you can do normal
things with them
um the only thing the reason it's worth
mentioning is you might see
um errors so if I go s x equals mu s
and I think if I comment that out
anyway
um there is coming if there isn't
already a warning that will be on this
um oh no wait where is the other way
around
defaults
there is a warning coming
well
that oh here we go I think I got it
nope
um there's a warning coming if you do
this so
what it means is there is now
potentially a difference between what
new s with no parameters used to do and
what it will do now because it used to
be that new s a new struct was exactly
the same as defaults right created a new
empty instance
because the developer of that struct can
now provide a Constructor that
equivalency isn't true anymore the
code's not going to do anything weird it
still does what the developer intended
but it could arguably change meaning so
I think the compiler team if they
haven't already they were talking about
a warning so if you do have code that
says uses the new keyword to create an
empty struct you might get a warning
that says hey this could change Behavior
just so you know that's what it's about
and you can either change it to default
and keep your same behavior or you can
leave it because you're doing what the
compiler what the the struct author
intended
um that's it that's C sharp 11. I think
that's all of it hopefully they all get
in otherwise I mean not uh what is it
June we got to November should be fine
uh any questions if three minutes
or you can go get a coffee or lunch
[Applause]